if you want to know how Pennywise lived
on after the events of its then stick
around to the end of this video hello
and welcome to horror history my name is
Professor C's world also known as Shaggy
also known as emo Abraham Lincoln and in
today's lesson we'll be discussing one
of Stephen King's most iconic monsters
Pennywise also known as it's also known
as the deadlights
also known as Robert gray Stephen King
hasn't really gone on record about his
inspirations for it's causing some to
believe that the events of the 1986
novel actually happened on the other
hand actual intelligent people drew
comparisons to a serial killer John
Wayne Gacy a birthday clown in Chicago
during the 1970s who did unspeakable
things to more than 30 victims he would
later stash the kids in the crawlspace
of his basement not so different from
Pennywise his penchant for dragging his
victims corpses into the sewers below
Derry Maine
Pennywise in the movie is depicted as
one of the forms of a shape-shifting
creature known as it who resided in the
lair at the bottom of Derry sewage
system for hundreds of years but in the
novel it's much more than that
so let's travel back to the inception of
its over 1 billion years ago in the
beginning there was an endless void
known as the macro verse which was
inhabited only by a celestial force
referred to as the other the other
created two additional inhabitants of
the macro verse one protector called
mattre and the turtle and one
shape-shifting entity called the
deadlights
the two would become natural enemies the
turtle was kind and all-knowing but did
not like to involve itself in any
conflicts and so stayed hidden in its
shell most often at some point the
turtle came out of its shell with a
stomachache and vomited out our universe
so everything you're sitting in right
now yeah that's actually puke
everything you've eaten today I think
you get the idea speaking of which its
main form of sustenance is fear because
of that fact
it's travelled to our universe to look
for food much like how I may travel to
Taco Bell when I'm done filming this
couple thousand or possibly even million
years ago it's discovered earth earth
was basically like a buffet for its
because humans have much more complex
imaginations than any species that had
discovered before
specifically the imaginations of human
children were especially attractive to
it
because they were capable of an
unprecedented level of fear it's arrived
on earth as a fiery meteoric object that
crashed into the land in North America
and would one day become known as The
Barrens in Derry Maine the impact scared
away the animal inhabitants such as
antelope fish bats and others the impact
trader was devastating but the area
would be taken back by trees and
wildlife over the years the impact also
sent it into a deep sleep possibly aided
by the fact that it became trapped in
the Ice Age in the Year 1715 it would
thought out and arise from the slumber
thus marking the beginning of the cycle
that would repeat roughly every 27 years
or it would awaken to feed on the
residents of Derry not too different
than how some mammals may eat sand then
go into hibernation during the winter
these incidents would often go
unrecorded in dairies history books but
that hasn't stopped locals from doing
some of their own research
the earliest known victims of its were a
party of 340 settlers called the dairy
company named after the town in Ireland
from which the hell they started to
create a civilization along the Kentucky
River and Derry Township became a
logging town still is my right boys in
1743 every single settler disappeared
without trace or explanation the entire
camp there are rumors of Indians but no
sign of an attack the town was left to
deserted other than one single house
that burned down in the same spot where
George Eden burrow would be killed 300
years later I'm guessing all of these
settlers were eaten by it's because she
had taken such a long nap after crashing
on earth and probably woke up especially
hungry
shortly after Derry Township was
rediscovered the town was re-established
and the Canal was built for easy access
to the Kentucky River it seems to be
about this time that it starts
experimenting with using the form of a
clown a picture from will Hanlan's album
dated to the 1700s shows a funny looking
man at juggling bowling pins on the
street near the canal he wasn't wearing
makeup but he did have the recognizable
Tufts of hair the next known event is in
1851 which is for 27 years cycles after
the disappearance of the settlements it
targeted a man named John Markson likely
using the power of the dead lights to
possess him and to do his bidding
it seems that humans who looked directly
into the dead lights are put into a
trance-like state where they're
controlled by his John poison his entire
family then killed himself with a white
nightshade mushroom keep in mind that
having someone else do its bidding
doesn't benefit
it directly but what it does do is
instill fear in everyone involved making
them more delicious meals for Pennywise
is basically the equivalent of putting
those little sauce packets on your taco
in 1856 the clown's image appears in a
political cartoon amongst some drunken
loggers at a bar
this illustration seems to predict the
next cycle which begins in 1877 when
four separate lynchings took place in
town and carries an to 1879 dairies
logging business was really booming at
that time and a group of Lumberjacks
stumbled upon another group finding them
completely hacked to pieces like a bear
coming out of hibernation it would
continue to come out every 27 years or
so to cause mayhem and feed on the
residents of Derry
the next cycle was especially bloody
coming up next we'll go into the
horrifying archives produced by its in
the early 1900's I had a ton of people
participate in the wast giveaway and
since you were all so excited about that
one I thought why not just do another
giveaway this time you'll float -
because the winner will be taking home
with this float merchandise to enter
make sure you're following seas world on
Instagram and like this post winner will
be chosen at random full rules can be
found in the video description in 1891
an Iron Works is built in Derry by the
Kitchener family and an article about
the opening of this facility is featured
in the paper the front page photograph
shows a crowd gathering to celebrate the
cutting of the ribbon and off to the
left of the crap the town can be seen
celebrating with a handspring this would
be a precursor to one of dairy's
deadliest events that took place at the
end of this cycle but first there was a
major incident that took place shortly
after its reawakening in September of
1905 the logging business in Derry had
become big enough that people started to
organize unions and one of these
organizers was named Claude hero he and
three colleagues were staying in a hotel
in Derry and during this day the
colleagues turned up dead in the
Kentucky River with missing body parts
in the word Union and pasted on each of
their bags it's unclear if this was the
result of penny wisest actions or if it
was just legitimately unhappy workers
but hero in an act of revenge took an
axe to a bar called the Silver Dollar
and took out the loggers that he thought
were responsible that night the
townspeople rioted after heroes arrest
they dragged him out of his jail cell
and lynched him on the side of town one
witness mentioned there was a guy doing
tricks and flips who he assumed was new
in town but no
that he seemed to stick around after
that this highlights one of the major
strengths of Pennywise other than
fabulous gymnastic skills it has the
ability to divide people and turn them
against each other it would later
attempt to use this tactic on the losers
club after Eddie Cass Brack suffers a
broken arm but their strong unity ends
up working has an advantage to them but
before we get there there's a lot more
of Penny wises history and Darion to
cover in 1906 an unexplained slew of
animal mutilations takes place these are
most likely connected to it now
sometimes when you've just eaten tacos
and you're a little hungry still and you
say you know what I'm gonna grab a big
burrito maybe some nachos and a large
soft drink for the road and that's
basically what Pennywise did before
going back into hibernation on Easter of
1906 the previously-mentioned ironworks
held an Easter egg hunt for all of the
kids in Derry during which the place
exploded leaving 102 dead 88 of which
were children at this point it's very
clear that a there's a problem plaguing
Derry and V it's occurring on a twenty
seven year cycle although only a select
number of dairy historians are aware of
it because Pennywise has actively used
its power to ensure that these disasters
stay out of the news the disasters that
took place from there on out were
largely ignored by the older townspeople
who were starting to become despondent
and preferred to ignore the problems
rather than acknowledge them it starts
to feel like dairy is just cursed with
random acts of violence but there's no
doubt that it is behind in 1929 a huge
group of citizens gunned down the
notorious Bradley Gang and several
witnesses were said to have seen a clown
participate in the brutal shooting
probably looked like something out of
The Dark Knight - the school bus each of
the witnesses to the Bradley gang
execution claimed that the clown had the
same gun as their own though none of
them shared the same gun in 1930 was the
first confirmed sighting of one of the
other recurring forms of it's the giant
bird that would later attack Michael
Hanlon was first spotted 28 years
beforehand by his father will Hamlin
this happened the night of the horrible
attack on the black spot nightclub in
which a racist organization known as the
Legion of white decency burned down the
popular african-american run jazz joint
and the place collapsed before dozens of
people had the chance to escape
just after narrowly making it out will
looked up and saw a giant bird with red
balloons tied to its wings a detail he
kept to himself
until he was on his deathbed from here
on we'll knew that Derry was no ordinary
town but he would never fully understand
that it was responsible like his son
I find out the following year one of the
worst floods in town history occur this
flood was almost as bad as the flood
that occurred in a common section that
one time when I had the wrinkly shard
and this flood uncle incidentally took
place during one of penny wisest waking
years Stephen King doesn't specifically
note when the sewer system that runs
under dairy was built but there's a good
chance based on one certain laws went
into effect in real life that this was
around the time of this big flood in the
book while these systems may have been
implemented to keep water levels from
overflowing to prevent another
disastrous flood they would
inadvertently become the home of penny
wise who built his lair deep within the
sewers of Derry from this point forward
future sightings of penny wise the
dancing clown are all connected to the
drain system whether it be a creepy
voice echoing from a drain a glowing
yellow pair of eyes emanating in a sewer
grates or a mysterious red balloon
floating around in a runoff pipe there's
been another murder
Velma Daniels Velma Daniels the poor
body was found this morning down by the
canal so if you come down here to play
come together like you are now
understand another image in will
Hamlin's photo album shows the
celebration at Wally's spa in 1933 when
the US alcohol prohibition ends the
group photo contains many men holding up
beer mugs and Pennywise drinking
champagne from a high-heeled shoe in the
corner Pennywise continues to make
appearances throughout dairies history
for example in 1945 when Japan
surrendered to end World War two a
parade is held in Derry to celebrate and
in one photograph the clown can be seen
dancing around in the background in the
50s Pennywise would bring the same photo
to life to terrorize the losers Club but
that is just one of the many events that
took place after the tragic incident
involving George Eden bro in 1957 coming
up we'll be analyzing one of the darkest
cycles in the history of Derry and the
reasons behind this particular spree
being cut short
it was a rainy October day in 1957
naturally as a six year old boy and
Georgie den bro wanted to go out and
play in it he suited up in his yellow
rain jacket and asked his big brother
Bill to make him a paper boat there you
go
the boat was pushed along the gutter in
the dairy Public Works drain system
which was managed by his father and Zack
down below then the boat began to pick
up speed and not wanting to lose it
little Georgie raced after not knowing
that he was rushing into his own watery
tomb he was unable to grab his boat
before it washed into the Seward Road
where a man in clown makeup introduced
himself as mr. Robert Brett
otherwise known as baby wise now penny
wise did not immediately become
aggressive first befriending Georgie and
tempting him to reach into the grates to
get his boat this is the very reason
that the shape-shifting it's so often
opted to use the clown form a penny one
is because most children love clowns or
at least they did before these came out
today he would probably have to take the
form of some fortnight youtuber or
something but he would use the form of
penny wise to lure children in his
children have the most active
imaginations and so make the richest
meals for his once he has drawn them in
he brings out his pulsing eyes and
razor-sharp teeth and devours them while
they are most afraid again much like I
do when I'm devouring my tacos that is
the fates that meets young Georgie he
was the first of a whole slew of deaths
and disappearances at the hand of it the
next was Betty rip some in December of
1957 penny wise spoke to her through the
drain in her home to make her more
afraid before attacking and leaving her
body ripped apart in your outer Jackson
strip don't tell me that
it's Betty Betty screams continue dad go
through the drains and haunt your
parents for the rest of this waking
cycle the next month when school is back
in session Ben Hanscom sees the clown
standing on the ice as he walks over the
canal bridge and Pennywise entices him
to come down into the sewers with the
prospect of balloons the promise of not
growing up and making it seem like the
sewers are basically a funfair hand
reaches up onto the bridge and Ben
recognizes it as the mummy from the
horror movie the moment felt wearing a
clown suits Ben is able to escape but
the same cannot be said for Sherrill
Lamonica who falls victim to Pennywise
that April then towards late April 3
year-old Matthew Clements is abducted by
Pennywise while riding his tricycle
around the house causing the police
chief to put a curfew into effect before
the end of that spring Mike Hanlon rides
his bike to the remains of the ironworks
that exploded in 1906 where he is
attacked by a giant bird who rises out
of the cellar hole and swoops in to try
to pick him up this is the same bird
that his father saw after the black spot
fire and combines mics for birds from
when he was attacked in its crib as a
baby and the fear instills in him the
night before by the movie Rodin reminds
me of the sound my 8th grade English
teacher used to use if he didn't have
proper MLA format Mike is able to escape
by cramming himself into the remains of
the smokestack where the bird couldn't
fit and pelting it with tiles that were
laying around Mike feels like some kind
of force was helping him throw the tiles
harder which I believe may have been the
turtle it was also around this time that
Stan Aerys had his encounter with it
skee had been bird-watching in the park
near the standpipe a water reservoir
that some kids had drowned in in the
1930s he hears a loud noise and realizes
that the door at the base of the
standpipe had been blown open he walks
over to investigate and he hears
carnival music at going through the dark
squishy footsteps approached him Stan
calls out to ask who's there and gets
the response the dead ones before he
escapes he sees the figures of the
drowned kids with purplish black jeans
and orange pom-pom button Stan's friend
Eddie kasparek has a similar experience
with it Eddie would sometimes play
around the train yard and one day a hobo
with leprosy climbs out from under the
porch of an abandoned old house number
29 niebolt streets Eddie is a
hypochondriac so this has a major effect
on him it's used this back to her
advantage when coming up with a form to
scare Eddie one day Eddie decides to
check under the porch to make sure
nobody's waiting for him in there and
sees it in the form similar to the hobo
but now crawling with disease and
wearing the silvery
suits the leper introduces himself as
Bob gray and crawls out from under the
porch to chase a Toa despite these four
victims escaping Pennywise would
continue to haunt them in their dreams
one night when Eddie is going to bed he
hears the lapper whisper it won't do any
good to run then at the beginning of the
summer then has this dream where he's
playing baseball and he hits a home run
as he's rounding the bases he sees a
clown waving to him in the trees he
doesn't remember the rest of the dream
but he wakes up with the wet Cola as if
he'd been weeping through the nights it
is doing everything in its power to
instill fear in these members of the
losers Club who escaped on the first
attempt but what would take place later
that summer would take things to a level
never before seen in dearies history
ever since the death of his younger
brother Georgie build Endre has been
having a lot of disturbing thoughts in
June of 1958 bill would go into
Georgie's room to look at his photo
album and under the influence of a it's
Georgie's school photo winks at Bill and
tells him see you soon
bill drops the book and blood drips out
of the pages but Bill's parents would
not be able to see the blood like the
kids of Derry can this kicks off
Pennywise his busiest month e adds
another boy goes missing this one named
Edward Corcoran Edward was fleeing from
his abusive father and decided to sleep
in the park by the canal where somebody
grabs his ankle it takes on the form of
Edwards dead brother Dorsett when Edward
ran it took the form of The Creature
from the Black Lagoon
the last thing he sees is the creatures
eyes going white and delights leaking
through the fins on its head this was
most likely Edward attempting to process
the dead last
shortly after Mike Hanlon finds Edwards
knife near the spot that he died here's
a splash come from the canal and sees
something moving inside of the pipe Mike
runs away but he has a feeling that
someone is chasing him all the while he
would go on to share his experiences
with the rest of the losers Club who
would also explain their encounters when
bill tells the story of his encounter
with Georgie's photo book Richie Tozier
says that he wants to see the album as
well so bill takes him over there only
to discover that Georgie's school photo
is missing from the book instead there's
a photo of old dairies somewhere near
the canal and bill and Richie see
themselves as a couple of sailors in the
sidewalk the picture begins to move and
Pennywise pops out of the canal but he
has the face of Georgie see these deep
fakes are getting away too good
wrong century at this point the real
build Enbridge's into the photo before
which he pulls his arm back out to
safety and closes the book bills hand is
bleeding
this scene foreshadows the final
confrontation with penny Wonka's bill
and Ritchie have always been the ones to
directly confront any wise an important
distinction is that they aren't the only
ones to fight back but they are the only
two who are willing to take the fight to
its domain this incident also marks the
first time that Ritchie starts to
realize that it is a monster with
supernatural properties rather than
physical ones bill and Ritchie would
once again take the fights of Pennywise
his domain when they decide to go to
Twentynine niebolt Street to investigate
Eddy's story about the leper they climb
into the basement and this time it takes
the form of the teenage werewolf that
Ritchie saw when he and a few others
went to the movie theater I feel like I
would just start laughing if my worst
fear just kept turning into these cheesy
50s horror movies I mean I can just
imagine oh no please don't kill me and
then the monster turns into like this
guy I'd be cracking up but I'm pretty
sure it was scary at the time bill
brings his father's gun but what ends up
hurting Pennywise more than the gun is
Ritchie screaming at it in his Irish cop
voice and throwing sneezing powder back
at it this is because it operates
unbelief just as their fear of its makes
them juicier targets their confidence
and childish humor can be used to fight
back against it by using the voice of an
authority figure and attacking the
werewolf with something that he believed
it would work he's fighting it with the
strongest weapon he has his imagination
as they ride away on Bill's bike the
clown comes after them wearing the same
Derry High School jacket that the
werewolf had on moments before it's not
really clear in the book if he's also
wearing the clown suit or if he's just
naked under the jacket actually I think
I'll just try not to think about that
when they look back later
Pennywise has disappeared presumably
taking refuge in the storm drain as we
get into late June Pennywise claims a
new victim Veronica Grogan a fourth
grader at the kneeble Church Street
school Veronica would be one of the
voices that Beverly Marsh hears coming
out of her drain later that week along
with the other victims like Matthew
Clements and Betty rips up the drain
spouts blood at her but like the blood
from Georgie's album her father is
unable to see it it tells Beverly that
she'll die if she tries
fight and then the sink erupts with
blood once again the last incident of
June occurs when Richie Tozier is
fleeing from some bullies and dips into
the park at city centre where there's a
statue of Paul Bunyan used to
commemorate dearies beginnings as a
logging town the statue comes to life
and stares Ricci in the face threatening
to eat him moments after he runs for it
Paul Bunyan destroys the bench but
Richie had just been sitting on with his
giant axe at the time Richie chalks this
up to being some kind of bizarre dream
but he would later realize that this was
one of the many forms of it's not much
happens in the first couple days of July
outside of Eddy kasparek momentarily
having a vision of a piranha wearing
orange pom-pom buttons while playing in
the Barrens the slow period is likely
because it is preparing the feast on a
day when dairies children would be out
in droves July 4th also known as
American Independence Day kind of a
shame that it didn't go with Cinco
DeMayo instead though it would have been
perfect for this taco analogy I've got
going on July 4th would be the first
time that Mike saw it's in the form of
Pennywise he was playing in the marching
band where he saw the clown handing out
balloons to kids on the streets the
sight of Pennywise waving at him gave
him a similar feeling to the encounter
with the bird then later on up the hill
he saw Pennywise again and wondered how
he could have gotten there so quickly
this time some of the kids he was
handing balloons to you were crying
and again Mike got a bad feeling as he
recognized this as the same clown from
all of those old photos in his father's
album it was most likely on this day
that it claimed the life of Leung and
Jimmy Cora and the rain would later push
his body into the sunlight two days
later on July 6 he was eventually found
with peck wounds all over his body
something that Mike would connect to his
encounter with the bird Jimi would be
the last random victim of it that summer
from this point on it would exclusively
go after Bill den bro and his gang of
misfits or Henry Bowers and his gang of
bull
[Music]
one of the most notorious bullies in all
of dairy perhaps even more feared than
Henry Bowers himself was the 12 year old
named Patrick hochstätter even a
sociopath like Patrick had fears of his
own for its to take advantage of them
Patrick developed a fear of leeches
while visiting a Brewster Lake when he
was 7 during the summer when Patrick was
12 it ambushed him at the junkyard where
he would often go and deposit dogs and
cats he had killed around town in a
discarded refrigerator to his shock
these leeches were also able to fly
perhaps Patrick was so crazy that the
leeches were the only semblance of a
true fear that it was able to find in
him because as he was being attacked he
saw a figure standing there it was
described as having a face like running
wax as if he didn't know what he wanted
to be this is the only known instance
that gives any real insight about what
it might look like while cycling among
form as Patrick would eventually pass
out from blood loss only to wake up when
it started devouring him Beverly Marsh
sees this incident with leeches as it's
happening and after Patrick is taken
away she hears Pennywise his laughter
reverberating from a pumping station
underground four hours later she brings
all of her friends to investigate where
they find a message written inside the
fridge in blood stop now before I kill
you all a word to the wise from your
friend penny wise penny wise leaves the
losers a second warning because at this
point each of them had survived at least
once and the slightest hint of
self-doubt begins to manifest itself
within the ancient creature this time
and Mike borrows his father's dairy
photo-album
the one that he recognized the clown in
the background of all of those old
photos when they stopped at the photo of
the world war two parade like the photo
that appeared in George's photo album
this one starts to move as well only
this time instead of Bill reaching into
the picture
Pennywise rushes up towards them and
hangs on a lamppost in the foreground
threatening once again to kill them all
his nose pressing up against the plastic
that the photo had been encased and it
rapidly changed forms to some of their
fears
Richie's werewolf Eddy's leper Ben's
mummy and Stan's dead boy at which point
Stan's slams the
shots that's when bill starts to realize
the truth it is afraid of them what bill
hasn't quite figured out yet though is
that it is especially afraid of the
power of their unity and that's why it's
next move comes against Eddie while he's
alone and at his weakest on July 20th
1958 Henry Bowers and his friends chased
down Eddie and break his arm
Eddie comes to Durham ambulams and
briefly sees Pennywise behind the wheel
that night Eddie has a dream about his
overprotective mother telling off his
friends who come to visit him at the
hospital by telling them that he doesn't
want to be friends with them anymore
which parallels a conversation that
happens in real life at the same time in
the dream Pennywise is also in the
hospital waiting room wildly dancing to
celebrate the breaking up of the losers
Club the real-life version of this
conversation is essentially the same and
it probably has some kind of influence
over mrs. Kasper act to encourage her to
try to remove Eddie's friends from his
life and this is further suggested by
the fact that the last image Eddie sees
in the dream is its toggling among the
many forms the last of which has his
mother's face the incident does cause
some turmoil inside the frantic group
but that doesn't stop them from
reuniting to take on it once again on
July 25th the seven losers arrive at 29
Mabel's each of them react differently
the house based on their own fears
upon entering they find a white clown
glove when they go upstairs they come
across a dirty magazine that winks at
bat the hallways they Traverse shrink in
on them in the eyes of the elves
plastered on the wallpaper begin to
bleed it's is doing everything it can to
scare them away without having to face
them directly they come across three
doors the first contains a bed which
explodes and oozes out black liquid the
second sounds like it has a loud buzzing
insect behind it but it turns out to
only be a moose blower which is
essentially a can that what's out a
constant noise as sort of an audio
scarecrow for farmers so the third door
is just a bathroom but the toilet seems
to have exploded leaving white porcelain
shards lying around the room it quickly
rushes up the pipe in what Ben perceives
to be its own form which we know to be
the dead lights it explodes out of the
pipe taking the form of the werewolf an
attacking villain bat Beverly fights
back with the slingshot loaded with
silver ball bearings which they believed
to be effective based on the werewolf
movies that they've seen she hits it on
the snout with her last shot sending
blood everywhere
however the losers are now defenseless
there's no remaining ammo
bev pulls back the slingshot again and
uses her belief to try to frighten it
sending it diving back into the drain
screaming I'll kill you all
not much happens in the next couple
weeks leading up to the big
confrontation but there is some activity
from its who is now more afraid than
ever of the losers Club and their power
it decided to bring on a new ally one
that wouldn't be limited by the power of
fear alone so it teams up with the next
biggest enemy of the losers Henry Bowers
after losing the switchblade that Henry
had attacked been with on the last day
of school Henry needed a new weapon in
early August he saw some red balloons
tied to his mailbox
the faces of the losers on each balloon
the balloons popped and the mailbox
swung down to show him the package it
was a knife the return address simply
said Robert Bret after this Henry
started hearing voices from the moon
commanding him to kill his father then
telling him to get a Victor and belch to
help him go after Beverly Marsh they end
up chasing the losers down into a
pumping station in the Barrens which is
connected to the sewer system where it
lives Victor and belch reluctantly go
down there with Henry I personally think
that it senses their reluctance and
decides to take them out first using the
form of Frankenstein's monster to
decapitate Victor then tearing belches
face in half when he tries to fight back
Henry goes on after the losers leaving
belch to die at the hands of EDS the
losers attempt to find its lair letting
Eddy lead the way with his impeccable
sense of direction they're cut off
however by its in the form of a giant
eye resembling the monster from a movie
that Ritchie had seen called the
crawling I gotta admit that one actually
sounds kind of scary
each of them is grabbed by one of the
eyes six tentacles besides Eddy who
pretends that his asthma aspirator is
battery acid and sprays it in the eye to
help drive it away next they're attacked
by the giant bird form but Stan uses his
extensive knowledge of birds to
determine that it isn't a real bird and
the fact that Stan doesn't believe in it
weakens the monster once more the seven
make it to a door containing the lair of
it a cathedral-like chamber covered in
spider webs it is here that they
encounter the true form of it's an
endless hairy crawling form composed of
lights that their human minds can only
interpret as a giant spider so that's
what they all see it as much to the
dismay of television audiences of the
90s
goes after their leader bill launching
him out of his physical body for a
mental confrontation on what Stephen
King describes as the ballroom floor of
eternity the turtle catches bill and
tells him he takes no stand in the
conflict that bill must fight on his own
then bill uses his mind to engage in
something known as the ritual of should
then cries out the line he thrusts his
fists against the posts and still
insists he sees the ghost a phrase that
was supposed to help him overcome his
stutter bill uses his faith in all of
the childish things he believes in to
mentally grab on to its mind and push
himself back towards the real world it
screams at bill to let go as he rejoins
his circle of friends in the real world
the spider flees into the depths of her
lair and Eddie tells them he could all
hear it and that it was dying all they
could do was hope that they defeated the
monster that had haunted Derry and
killed it they make a Blood Pact to
return to finish the job should it ever
rise again so the 1957-1958 cycle ends
prematurely with its going into an early
sleep after the defeat at the hands of
the losers Club but as always 27 years
after the awakening in 1957 it would
come back with a vengeance on the people
of Derry than those who had beaten it so
many years before in July of 1984 a
festival was held to celebrate the
anniversary of Gerry's canal at the
festival there's a little dispute
between two parties on one side there
are three guys Steve Dube and John
Garten and Christopher unwind they're
harassing a homosexual couple Don
Haggerty and Adrian melon the initial
dispute is broken up by police but they
have another confrontation later
regarding in Dubey throw melon off of a
bridge or Pennywise the clown
waits but
melon might have survived the fall but
Pennywise drags him under the bridge and
bites into his armpit with huge teeth at
this time thousands of I heart dairy
balloons similar to the balloon that
melon had earlier at the dairy canal
days festival emerge and hit the bottom
of the bridge melons body is found with
stab wounds bite marks and a missing
armpits
Pennywise has returned parallels one of
the many other tragedies occurring in
dairy for the last 300 plus years in one
major way the incidence is largely
ignored by witnesses and news outlets
however this time there's one person
taking special interest the town
librarian Michael Hanlon one of the
losers who stayed in Derry all of these
years to keep an eye out for it
should the creature ever return Mike
wanted to be sure that it was back
before contacting his old friends he
stood by as Pennywise claimed why life
of Lisa all breads on October 18 and
then Steven Johnson at Memorial Park
near the end of the year on February
14th 1985 two more children disappeared
Denis Torrio and loriann winter Barger
Dennis's body was found in the Barrens
with a photo of George Eden brown this
is the same photo that disappeared from
the photo album when Bill and Ritchie
went to look in 1958 by March mike is
pretty convinced that it has come back
but wants to have proof before alerting
the others bodies continue to pile up
Don Roy a 13 year old girl is found
decapitated in McCarren Park on October
24th 16 year old Adam Talt is killed and
mutilated by penny woman two weeks later
on May 6 Pennywise emerges through the
pipes as two year old Frederick Cowan
uses the restroom and drowns him in the
toilet bowl his mother was outside and
she heard screaming repeated flushing of
the toilet and laughter that didn't
sound human when she found her son she
had to be taken to a mental hospital in
Bangor it was only one week after when
Jeffrey Hawley was found torn apart and
Basie parked near the canal John fury
and Jerry Bellwood two fifth grade
classmates were killed before the end of
May Sheree was found with his legs torn
off under the porch at 29 the Balt
street and Bellwood turned up near a
cement retaining wall on Kansas Street
with the words come home written over
and over in blood a direct message to
Mike who would soon make the six phone
calls to remind his friends of the
promise they once made the news was too
much for Stanton who took his own life
in the meantime it would also be calling
back
old friend Henry Bowers who is sitting
in juniper Hill mental asylum began
hearing the same familiar voice of penny
wise speaking to him through the moon
when the remaining losers reconvened at
a Chinese restaurant upon returning to
Derry penny wise leaves them warnings in
their fortune cookies including eyes
bugs and more this is a symbolic way for
its to tell them that they'll meet
unhappy fortunes if they try to fight
the losers go for individual walks
around town while they wait for the
memories of the summer of 58 to come
back during this time penny wise
terrorizes each of them with the belief
that they'll not be able to win as they
once did I think the reason it's become
so confident is a combination of factors
the losers have grown up lost their
imaginations lost one of their members
Stan and forgotten about Derry for the
most part however one thing that I think
it didn't count on was the fact that
despite them growing older many of them
still worked in creative fields Beverly
designs dresses then designs buildings
Richie is a radio DJ known for his
creative voices and Bill is an author of
fiction a concept that those people who
think Pennywise is real don't seem to
understand each of the losers goes
somewhere that they used to spend time
at in Derry then visits the library
where Pennywise taunts him from the
landing I love that part it also scared
then using the form of Dracula and
taunting him about the death of Stan
before disappearing it leaves behind a
balloon with a message have a good day
tonight you die in the movie Pennywise
spends more time warning the losers that
they should get out of town which I
don't really find to fall in line with
the character so much because in the
novel it comes back and wants revenge on
those who bested him so it wouldn't
really make sense for him to lure them
all back and then make them leave again
Eddie takes his walk down memory lane
not down memory lane because that
probably is in a real place but rather
and down West Broadway where he comes
upon the tractor Bros truck Depot or at
least what's left of it this is where
all the kids used to play baseball ed he
sees a leper version of belch Huggins
climb over the fence and then the canvas
squares that they used to use his base
is fly into the air and take after him
Tony tracker one of the co-owners of the
Depot comes out of the ground at home
plate Eddie also sees a zombie version
of his childhood crush Gretta Bowie and
of Patrick Hawks daughter Beverly goes
back to her old apartment to see if her
dad is still
but a woman named mrs. Kirsh has taken
up residence and invites her in for tea
mrs. Kerr starts rotting before her eyes
before dropping the fact that her father
was Robert gray also known as Pennywise
the dancing clown Bev also realizes that
the tea she's drinking tastes like crap
from the sewer and it is at this point
that snapped that means probably gonna
be so outdated by the time this video
even comes out missus Kirsh turns into a
witch and chases Beverly out as the
whole place turns to candy like the
house from Hansel and Gretel as she runs
out she hears her father's voice call
out but when she turns back she sees the
clown holding the detached leg of a
child's there's also a balloon with the
words it came from outer space the name
of a horror movie from the 50s that also
works with the origin of it from it by
Stephen King well I could probably go on
about how many times I've had an issue
trying to distinguish the monster if
from the word it's let's instead move on
to Richie Tozier Richie goes back to
city center where the Paul Bunyan statue
turns into Pennywise holding two
balloons one reading Richie Tozier is
all dead Rock Show penny wise tells him
that the eye is waiting for him below a
reference to the crawling eye that they
encountered on their first trip to the
sewers he looks back up and the clown
has been replaced by a Buddy Holly
statue and looking back on it now it's
interesting the note that Pennywise the
clown looked just like Buddy Holly
roughly nine years before anyone knew
who Rivers Cuomo was Richie feels a
sharp pain in his eyes possibly a
connection to the smoke in his eyes
during the smoke hold ritual that they
did his kids he blinks his contacts back
to normal and yes this is me blinking
for all you people who comment and say I
never blink and everything goes back to
normal but he still hears penny wisest
laughter in the back of his head late
that night it takes the form of Victor
Criss to break Henry out of the mental
asylum Victor's body still has the voice
of penny wise though and he explains
that Henry must kill the losers because
Henry can hurt them regardless of if
they believe in him or fear him in order
to escape they must first get past one
of the juniper Hill guards John Koons
it first attacks him using the penny
wise form then turns into a giant dog
which is a Doberman just like the guard
dogs at the asylum in malls Koons to
death that night the losers reconvene at
the library where it taunts them with
strange visions including one of Stan's
11 year old head which is stuffed with
feathers possibly a reference to the
often used bird form of it
you know what it's true what they say we
all float down here and you will - his
eyes open and they are the eyes of
Pennywise the head bursts leaving behind
a mess of blood
the losers decide to call it at nights
but Henry Bowers has other ideas
Henry ambushes and attacks Mike who's
wrapping up at the library then while
prowling the streets at 2:00 a.m. he
sees a sewer grate with a balloon tied
to it don't waste your time on Henry cuz
the voice inside his head tells him that
a ride hasn't been sent for him and in
1958 Plymouth Fury pulls up now I know
this isn't an episode of things you
missed this is horror history but let me
give you a freebie anyways the car
matches the description of Kristine from
another Stephen King book Christine the
driver of the car was a zombie version
of belch who doesn't speak the entire
car ride until the end when penny wisest
voice comes out of his mouth and tells
him to shut up and get the losers I can
only imagine what kind of review Henry
would have left on Zombie uber Henry
would go on into the hotel and managed
to injure Eddie Cass brag just as he did
in 1958 but in 1985 it's had one more
trick up her sleeve that none of the
losers Club would have seen coming
before the final showdown Beverly Marsh
never really escaped her abusive father
yes she did get out of Derry and yes
that was the last time she ever spoke to
her dad but Beverly ended up falling
into the same trap again when she
married a man named Tom Rogan who
treated her even worse than al Marsh did
tom was able to ascertain Beverly's
location after she left him to reunite
with her childhood friends in Derry and
he found himself waking up in Holiday
Inn in Maine where he found a balloon
tied to his bathroom doorknob the voice
of it spoke to him through the balloon
and told him to do its bidding at this
point I think it's important to look
back at its human service the fact that
it was able to manipulate some people to
do her bidding but not others is
interesting to me in fact it seems that
it's is only able to manipulate people
who already have a lot of evil undone
there is also a nurse that it
manipulates later named Mark Lamonica
the brother of Cheryl lamonica who was
killed in 1958 it sends him with a
scalpel to try to finish off Mike in the
hospital and King describes him as being
an easy target for it's because he's a
drug addict on the other hand it seems
like its rival the turtle is able to
admit if you
like good people the losers Club members
often describe some kind of helping hand
aiding them like when Mike was throwing
the tiles at the bird and he feels
something helping him throw harder than
usual now if only we could get the Cubs
bullpen to get a little help from the
turtle then we'd really be in business
Beverly's husband Tom isn't the only
spouse who followed their partner into
dairy because Bill's wife
Audra also made the trip in order to
ensure the opportunity for revenge its
uses tom to capture Audra and bring her
into the sewers leaving her purse at the
foot of the pumping station has bait for
bill because of this he Eddy Ben Beverly
and Ritchie must go to face it before
they're ready and this time they're on a
rescue mission even with everything
turned in its favor even with only five
losers to kill now as opposed to seven
it's feels fear again as they approach
so Pennywise tries to intimidate them a
little more on their drive to the Barons
Pennywise speech through the car radio
first reading an ad for the Richie
Tozier all dead rock show then and
Georgie's voice berates bill telling him
you let it kill me they turn off the
radio which must have been a good
indicator for it's that bill was still
pretty rattled by the idea that he could
have possibly been responsible for what
happened to Georgi I think it's for this
reason that the first forum that the
losers encounter after climbing down to
the sewers is Bill's younger brother
Bill starts to feel guilt and he feels
that he should have been the one to die
the others need him to come to the
realization that this Georgi isn't real
and he's able to do so by repeating the
phrase he thrusts his fist against the
posts and still insist he sees the ghost
just like last time this hurts it who
retreats into the inner sanctum
you may have noticed throughout this
video that I refer to its using the
female pronouns there's a reason for
that and when they get to the inner
layer at the heart of the sewer system
they discover that the dead lights that
they interpret as a spider has an egg so
it's female and it's pregnant though I
do have serious questions about who in
their right mind would have actually
knocked it up but actually let's try not
to think about that once again it goes
for Bill which if you think about it
makes sense he's the leader he's
probably the biggest threat to it seeing
as how he became a writer and he's still
flowing with creativity and it's his
wife that has been captured so he's the
most motivated just like when they were
young and bill leaves his physical body
and enters the void it tells him that
the turtle is dead and won't be able to
help him this time which he doesn't
believe at first but later concludes to
be true when they passed by the turtles
empty shell bill tried to mentally seize
its tongue like he
during the ritual of chode when they
were kids but this time he misses its
grip and drifts deeper into the void in
the physical chamber Ricci realizes
something is wrong and confronts the
spider using his Irish cop voice Ritchie
has then whacked into the cosmic void as
well and he's able to successfully
engage in the ritual of chud Ritchie
takes bill's hands and threatens to kill
its if it doesn't bring them back to the
real world
they almost lose their grip on it but
they're able to safely get back to their
physical bodies just before they arrive
Eddy is trying to hurt the spider with
his aspirator just like you did in 1958
but when it comes back to the physical
body of the spider it bites down and
rips Eddie's arm off before we're
treating into the dark depths of the
lair this time Ritchie and bill don't
want to let it get away just as they
pursued its 2:29 Diebold Street as kids
they follow the spider further into the
dark Beverley stops to comfort Eddy in
his final moments while Ben finds the
trail of eggs left behind by it and one
by one attempts to stomp them all out
now it was becoming more afraid than
ever it sensed Ritchie and Bill's
pursuit it sensed the death of its young
and it began to turn white its turned
back to Ritchie and Bill now beginning
to let off the dead lights from within
the arachnid creature begged them to let
her go offering them a power success in
the prospect of 500 year live spill and
Ritchie began to feel the power of
another not it's not the turtle
but the celestial forest I mentioned way
back at the beginning of this video even
before I started talking about the tacos
that created both of them bill hears the
sound of the spiders heart pounding out
like an enormous drum he punches his way
into it reaches for the heart and
crushes it in his mane
the creature jerked and quivered but as
it died the light faded Fermi's bill
heard the voice of the other telling him
son you did real good Ritchie was
basically passed out at this point and
benefiting out over a hundred eggs and
he thinks he's gotten them all
Audra falls from the webbing she strung
up in and lies crumpled on the ground in
a catatonic state Eddy has died and
Beverly's pack of matches is their only
source of light and hope to get out
meanwhile a huge storm brews above them
over Derry and the flood that would
ensue is a metaphorical washing out of
all of the bad history that the town had
endured over the 300 or so years of its
existence the flood would end up
destroying much of Main Street and any
buildings near the canal that were swept
away the losers were able to climb
directly out of the destroyed sewer
pipes to the street above as they left
Derry their memories of every
that it happened between them and its
began to fade once again but this time
even Mike who is still recovering in the
hospital would lose his memories of the
horrific occurrences that took place in
and under Derry Maine at this point in
the story it is widely believed that
it's the creature that had caused so
much pain and taken so many lives was
dead however some might say that simply
isn't true Stephen King would go on to
write many more novels that either take
place in or reference the town of Derry
some of them seem to imply that the
battle with the losers Club in 1985 was
not the end of Pennywise
[Music]
a few years passed before the events of
Stephen King's 1987 book the
Tommyknockers where an alien
intelligence possesses the nearby
village of Haven Maine a 15 year old boy
named Tommy jaclyn is sent with 13 year
old Hester Brookline to retrieve as many
car batteries as they could manage
during the stop in Derry
Tommy notices a clown with shiny silver
dollars for eyes staring at him through
an open sewer manhole he brushes it off
as an effect of the aliens mutations on
his mind but more evidence would come
over a decade later in the year 2001
dreamcatcher is another alien possession
novel by Stephen King in which a
character named mr. gray which in itself
could be a nod to the human form of it
Robert gray comes across the former spot
of the Derry standpipe the water storage
structure that was destroyed in the
flood at the end of it in 1985 there's
now a memorial in its place it reads to
those lost in the storm may 31 at 1985
and to the children all the children
loved from Bill Ben Bev Eddie
rich Stan Mike the losers Club but there
is another message which has been spray
painted in red jagged letters over the
top of the memorial which reads
Pennywise lives this is pretty solid
proof that Pennywise does indeed live on
and dairy because most of the town
doesn't know who Pennywise is and those
who do don't have the motives to deface
this memorial like Pennywise does but
how does Pennywise live it was pretty
clear that the dead lights faded and its
brandings disappeared from the door
leading to the spiders lair
some believe that the 27-year cycle
simply can't be stopped that the losers
Club never had the ability to kill it to
begin with and that Pennywise simply
went back to sleep however I have a
different theory at the end of the
battle in 1985 Ritchie and Bill finish
off the spider while Ben stomps on all
of the eggs using only a pack of matches
to find them and stomp all of them out
when they reconvene Ben tells them I
stamped out over a hundred I think I got
all of them I pray to God you did
Ritchie tells him then they flee from
the chamber
it seems pretty inconclusive to me
there's even a thoughts Ben has earlier
as he's stepping on all of them how many
how many eggs didn't I read that spiders
can
thousands or millions so I would
theorize that at least one of these eggs
went unnoticed and it was reborn into a
new physical body this new it's would
also have the shape-shifting ability and
thus would also be able to take the
exact same form as Pennywise it also
makes sense for the new it's to use this
form again because it seems to know all
about things happening in dairy and
would be able to pick up on the idea
that the kids in town are scared of this
clown there's one more possible piece of
evidence that Pennywise lives in stephen
king's 2014 book mr. Mercedes this one
doesn't take place in dairy but rather
in Cleveland Ohio where a serial killer
wears a clown mask to conceal himself
one of the characters compares it to the
TV movie about the clown in the sewers
he's talking about the TV mini-series
adaptation of its that came out in 1990
so apparently this adaptation also
exists in Stephen King's universe but
you'd have to think that in order for
that to be possible someone somewhere
had to have seen the real Pennywise and
been inspired by it so I think this is
another piece of evidence that Pennywise
is alive probably as one of the forms of
the new it after the events of the novel
edge so what does that hold for the
future
could we one day see a sequel to it
during a reddit AMA in 2013 Stephen King
addresses the question I don't think I
could bear to deal with penny wise again
too scary even for me so maybe we'll
continue to see penny wise lurking in
the shadows of some of King's future
works or maybe he'll change his mind
after seeing how much people love the
2017 and 2019 adaptations of it let me
know what you think in the comments
click the playlist on the left to see
the complete history of some other
characters from it and remember to
subscribe to seize these worlds for new
Horrors every week bring the death bell
for notifications and I'll see you in
the next one
assuming we both survive
[Music]